let's talk a little bit about Twitter
the stock is down significantly since
the last earnings report it's down over
the last it is it is it's down over the
last verses six months since Jack took
over as CEO why do you think investors
aren't feeling it six months is a really
short amount of time in the long scheme
of things I mean Twitter's been around
for ten years it takes a long time to to
like take over a CEO and turn the ship
around it's not like an overnight thing
I think Wall Street thinks in quarters
and and you know people like Jack they
think in decades they think decades
ahead so if it's maybe it's down now or
whatever but he's got these long-term
plans like Jeff Bezos does you know
don't invest in us if you don't like it
but I'm gonna like I'm building a
company of enduring value and you'll see
in 10 years how great it is you know so
hi I'm with Jack on this like he seems
to have gone into some kind of time
chamber with like a master CEO adviser
and come out after 40 years only two
years older and he's great he's like
super good at this now so you think
it'll take a decade I mean how long no
it won't take a decade but you know it
could take longer than six months I mean
give it a couple of years and I'm
holding on to my equity that's for sure
jack is it's so great that Jack is back
I'm just so happy because the
combination of him and Adam being are
just gonna this thing is gonna the world
needs Twitter it's not going away it's
it's a it's now a staple it can't be
unneeded anymore you know what do you
mean it's like once it's there it's
there and it's it's only gonna get
better and
everything else so it's just a temporary
thing so facebook is now getting into
live Twitter you know though for the
last 10 years has been the place for ya
live a facebook has incredible resources
go to scale this do you think that
Twitter can grow significantly bigger
than it is right now or is it is it fine
as a smaller platform for influencers
and is that just what it becomes well
both are true but I always thought of
it's funny because I Jason Goldman a
friend of mine used to work at Twitter
and work with me at Google he always
accuses me of spinning things but i just
think i have a positive attitude so you
know when i when people say like well
twitter only has 300 and something
million people using the service and
facebook has one point something billion
people using the service i'm like great
that's how many more people can use
twitter like you know like there you go
that's the number that's the number
Twitter can grow too and people are like
are you spending this I'm like no that's
just that's an aspirational number that
we have to reach what about snapchat
what about Instagram which were we're
also seeing surpass your in terms of
users I don't know I don't know I use
Instagram because I like to put the
little filters and stuff on there but I
kind of stopped using it because my
pictures were always with my kid and
people were complaining like really is
it's all you're gonna do and I was like
pretty much so I use it a lot less now
because it's the same thing every single
time like look at Jake isn't he cute but
I you know everything grows everything
you know everything grows some things
fall you know it depends on the value if
it's delivering value it's here to stay
Twitter delivers value because
historically getting the information
first is key it makes you win and you
know the same thing with jelly getting
information the right information the
good quality answers rather than just
you know looking through results you win